you made quite an entrance my friend I'm
colorful right now CC Miyake I found
this in Japan and in Japan that's where
I find all my crazy wardrobe outfits you
know that's where I get styled you know
for the tea but yeah I wanted to come
loud and you know colorful I mean if the
Latin Grammys right Latinos are loud and
passionately exactly you know I got my
big performance tonight with Nicky Jam
so that it comes frog you know yeah you
know maybe the laughs in this one where
have you been saving it for the Grammy
yeah you saved the best for last for
damn sure
talk to me about this performance
because obviously it's the Latin Grammys
of amazing amazing collaborations but
what are you and Nicky Jam have up your
sleeve oh this performance is gonna
knock people's socks off I mean it's a
lot of a lot of activity happening on
stage plus it's our first time really
playing out ha lay out together and I
think this record is like the
culmination of EDM for the reggaeton in
a big way I really think it's gonna make
some ways tonight well I want to know if
you're gonna be doing your signature
move is a cake being thrown in Grammys
audience does Will Smith have to be
ducking for cakes that's always a
surprise man no desserts always at the
end yeah I'm gonna say what's your time
slot when you guys perform you tonight
if at the end I'm gonna expect a king
I'm not sure when our time slot is but
uh I know that Nicki gem J Balvin do
their thing and then you know who are
you hoping to rub elbows with today
maybe like hook up a collaboration you
know be like hey we should work together
Anita I just talked to Anita so I
definitely want to work with her I got
bunny you know he's like one dude I
definitely want to work with but there's
a lot of homeys out here you know a lot
of good friends out here
Osuna and you know obviously J Balvin
you know so there's a lot of a lot of
amazing artists so many to pick from
that's a crazy trip yeah so the your BTS
song wasted on me still on my rotation I
can't get out of my head I mean when can
we expect that video the video all the
video is gonna be epic yeah it's gonna
it's cultural is it it's gonna be a big
one everyone how would you describe it
in one word I uh cultural okay yeah cuz
I don't want to give away too much you
know I really feel
a special video it's the most my most
special video that I've ever been part
of and put together so I'm very excited
about it and the guys are they get it I
don't want to say anything like a video
cuz like it's it's gonna be it's gonna
be a moment you know yeah the moment
will be waiting man well good luck
tonight have fun
[Applause]